والشيء الآخر الذي أشير إليه هو أن
كل هذا يحدث في الليل يتدرب الجيش الأمريكي
باستمرار في الليل ولكن هذا يمثل
تحديًا بالنسبة للطيارين الذين يتعين عليهم
القيام بذلك ولكن عندما تتحدث عن
نظارات الرؤية الليلية عندما تكون على متن
طائرة  وسأعرض عفواً
عن هذا ولكن لديك نظارتان
مثل هذه أمام وجهك وهذا هو
المكان الذي يمكنك رؤيته باستخدام
الإضاءة من كل ما هو موجود هناك
نجوم ضوء القمر الليلة الماضية لقد بحثت عنه
القمر روز ظهر أمس إنه
تم تعيين الساعة 3 59 هذا الصباح ، لذا كان لديهم
ضوء القمر الجيد حوالي 50
إضاءة من إضاءة القمر
الليلة الماضية وهذا يساعد على الرؤية باستخدام
نظارات الرؤية الليلية ، المشكلة هي أنه
نطاق محدود من القدرة على الرؤية
لأنك حرفيًا قد اختزلت إلى هذا
شفاط الصودا في المنظار الخاص بك ،
والشيء الآخر الذي
سأقوله إنك تعلم أنهم سوف ينظرون إلى
ما قد يحدث كما
قال أورين أيضًا أنه قد يكون
ضربة سلكية يمكن للطائرة أن تصطدم ببعضها البعض
أنت تعلم أن
دوار الذيل الخاص بهم يمكن أن يصطدم بشجرة أثناء
خروجهم من منطقة الهبوط أو
الذهاب إلى منطقة الهبوط ولهذا السبب
قال الجنرال لوفيس إنهم
سيحضرون خبراء ، وهناك
مركز أمان في Fort Rucker Alabama
يرسل على الفور  فرقًا
للتحقيق في هذا النوع من الحوادث